[Music]
welcome back to SEO foundations in this
video we're going to cover off site
optimization and link building from the
perspective of search engine hyperlinks
act as votes of popularity of content on
the web in this lesson we will be
discovering the major role that link
building plays in the work of SEO and we
be considering how you might start link
building for your organization
describe the role that links play on
influencing search results list and
explain the three basic principles of
link billing explain how links from
different web sites impact search
rankings differently summarize why links
from social media sites generally do not
have a direct influence on search
rankings avoid potentially dangerous
link building tactics such as buying
spammy links in the section on on-page
optimization we talked about factors
that centered on relevancy in this
section we're going to go in a different
direction we're going to talk about the
signals that focus on popularity so what
is popularity meet in this context well
it's actually quite simple popularity
always relates to links to hyperlinks on
the web so you have seen these when you
see the typically blue text that is
underlined what this is is a tool it's a
a HOF technically in HTML that is
pointing from one web document to a
different one this is a pretty simple
concept I imagine you already know this
so what does it mean from an SEO
perspective well it turns out that this
gigantic group of signals the ones
related to hyperlinks are in our and
historically have been the lion share of
signals that the search engines process
when trying to rank pages now there's
one big problem with these from an SEO
perspective is that they are
historically and today very difficult to
influence this is because they do not
take place on your website they take
place elsewhere it's other people who
are linking to you generally speaking
and this makes them very very difficult
to have an influence on so this is a
good thing in a bad thing it's a good
thing because it turns out to be a great
metric for ranking web documents it's a
bad thing because it's hard for us to
make an impact on day to day level hands
down the most time-consuming and
difficult part of SEO is link building
now there's a lot of reasons for this
primarily because it's constantly
changing and because of all the elements
that are involved with this but the big
the bigger takeaway here is that there's
no one-size-fits-all solution for link
building you have to take the context of
your business or of your website and you
have to apply general principles to that
so in this video we're going to cover
these general principles so you can
figure out how to apply those to your
business these principles are and I
think these are the most clever and the
most important ones are creating link
worthy content proactively participate
in an off-site engagement and utilizing
offline relationship
the tried-and-true method for building
links is creating content that's
optimized for humans so let me explain
what this means the currency of the
internet if you will is the content
itself that's why people go on they want
to read the newest article or they want
to see the newest video whatever it may
be that is what has been true since the
beginning and I have no doubt will be
true going forward so as an SEO or as an
online marketer in general you can use
this to your advantage
creating the content that people are
going to want to share with their
friends whether they're going to want to
cite in any kind of paper or whatever
they're working on that is a
tried-and-true way of gaining links this
is what we call the power of content you
can do all kinds of bells and whistles
you can go do these news tactics you can
try all these different things out but
at the end of day what's really
important is the content itself so this
is what I focus on this is where 80% of
my time goes on when I'm working on link
building it's on the content itself can
I create something that is just truly
that is so truly great that someone
essentially has to link to it this is
what I focus on trying to answer and
while there is no simple answer that go
in asking that question always said to
in the right direction
the next strategy that I want to talk
about is actually very counterintuitive
so if you're trying to build links to
your own website I've found one of the
most effective ways and this is
consistently true is to engage off your
own site now this doesn't make any sense
right why would you work on other
people's websites if you're trying to
promote your yourself well think about
human beings human beings are much more
likely to link and give back to people
to human beings that they know well so a
lot of the time I spend what I'm doing
link building is been off site engaging
with others so sometimes this is through
social media so I'll use whatever the
latest social network is and I'll chat
with people there who have similar
interests or have similar interests to
what I'm trying to promote be a
different topic or be it a new industry
altogether I'll spend a lot of time
promoting others and a lot of times
chatting with other people building up
genuine real relationships with human
beings so that when it comes time for
them to write an article or when it's
when they're ready to link out to other
people I'm the first person they think
to and they link back to my website one
of the reasons that link building is so
hard is because the internet moves so
fast what worked yesterday might not
work tomorrow so one of the most clever
and easy ways to avoid this problem is
to just simply go offline utilize some
of the relationships that you have off
of the Internet in order to benefit on
the Internet
something I'd try to do all the time
because it consistently works by far the
easiest favors to cash in on are the
ones that you're already owed so this
might be from your friends who work with
it might be from friends who from
childhood these are people who you
actually know in the real world who are
much more likely to help you when you're
trying to promote new content online so
when I'm trying to do link building one
things I focus on is people that I know
in the real world so this can be lots of
things this can be personal friends who
happen to have websites and blogs this
can be from the competition you have or
friendly allies you have in your space
just saying hey we're looking for these
kind of things can you help us out maybe
I'll help you out somewhere else
it's utilizing these relationships that
exist elsewhere so that you can start
gaining these links yourself if that
doesn't work if maybe you don't have any
friends in these arenas you can always
go to local businesses and local
agencies so sometimes this is like
government owned things sometimes this
is just third parties all together
there's lots of things that they need
help with that you as a business owner
or you is trying to promote some client
may be able to help them with and if you
can help them offline they're more much
more likely to help you online will link
building it's very important to
understand that not all links are
created equally a link coming from the
homepage of CNN is going to provide a
lot of what we call link equity it's
gonna have a lot of popularity metrics
tied to it and so it's going to be more
valuable to you and help you rank higher
where as a link also coming from the
home page but let's say Joe schmo's a
spam blog that is not going to be
particularly helpful for you and it
actually in some cases could hurt you so
when you're going out and doing link
building make sure that you can stand
behind the source of the link is coming
at you this could be in a good example
from like a government website where
it's trusted and a bad example this
could be from a website that you would
not normally go to even on your own in
addition to that there's different kinds
of links depending on the direction that
they're going so if a link is coming
towards you towards your website that's
called an inbound link these are the
ones that are very helpful for
popularity metrics that we've talked
about
there's also outbound links these are
links that you linking to other people
now generally there's a big
misconception about this that you think
you would not want to link out to other
people but if you just follow the
natural chain of events and you look at
people who are writing blogs without SEO
in mind you'll see that they are linking
out naturally and it's these natural
patterns that the search engines are
looking for so there's absolutely no
problem in linking out just as long as
it's two sources that you actually do
trust
so there's inbound links resound found
links there's links that have a lot of
popularity value so like from a
established government website or from
something popular like CNN there's also
links that are inbound that are not
going to have as much value for you you
probably don't wanna spend your time
building now regardless of where your
links are coming from it's important to
look out for one particular attribute
it's called rel nofollow' rel nofollow'
was a tool that is originally developed
to combat comment spam like on blogs
you'd have lots of people who are
leaving completely irrelevant comments
so they can link back to their own
website and get creative without it that
does not work at all today one of the
primary reasons for that is the search
engine introduced something called rel
nofollow' what they said here's a link
that's going out from our website but I
do not stand behind it and it does not
pass any credit a lot of times our doing
link building you'll get a link what
you're very proud of coming from
somewhere very popular but then realize
that it has this attribute attached to
it nofollow and which means you will not
get any credit for it so make sure that
when you're doing your link building the
link coming at you that you've earned
does not have this attribute associated
with it otherwise you will get no credit
for it now that you understand what
nofollow is let's talk about the biggest
use case for this social media most of
the links that we see in social media
are valueless this is because they are
either hidden from search engines
entirely this mostly happens on Facebook
or they're visible to search engines but
they use this row this rel nofollow
attribute which means that they're
useless
so while social media does have many
many benefits SEO and particularly links
value from SEO is not one of the direct
benefits of participating in social
media now that we've covered some of the
link building dues let's talk about some
of the link building don'ts so these are
things that you should not do because
you'll be wasting your time and possibly
more importantly your money the first
one is spam so we have all seen this
online when you go somewhere and you see
just a bunch of spammy links links that
are clearly written only for machines
only for search engines a lot of times
these will
the name of pharmaceutical drugs on them
a lot of times they'll have just can be
completely irrelevant to the content
while these have worked in some
instances they are certainly not a best
practice and they are certainly not a
long-term strategy so I never recommend
trying to invest in spammy links this
way because it is not going to
ultimately help you in fact in many ways
it'll probably hurt you so do not go out
of your way to try to get spammy links
the next one is buying links these are
tows closely tied together now buying
links is when you go out and try to buy
sometimes relevant sometimes irrelevant
links and again this is something that
had it worked
sometimes historically not always my
biggest problem with this is not so much
the ethical problem although there is
one their search engine of clues said
not to ever do this my biggest problem
with it is that you could not calculate
an accurate ROI on this so if you spend
a dollar on this you don't know if
you're going to make a dollar or two
dollars back you have no idea there's no
way to accurately measure this so you
have no idea if this is valuable to you
or not where as opposed to if you're
creating valuable content you can
measure that and you can directly tie it
to sales so your money dollar for dollar
spent much much more effectively on
content than it is on buying links so
how do I recommend do not spend your
time or your money buying links the last
one is acquiring reciprocal links so
reciprocal links as you can imagine are
links they go in a circle you link to
somebody and they link directly back to
you now in the natural web when no
marketing is taking the place into this
there's no kind of manipulation trying
to go on that happens that happens all
the time so don't go out of your way and
be afraid of this happening so one news
site will very regularly link to another
news article and that article might link
back to them somewhere else that happens
so don't stress about this too much but
don't go out of your way to try to build
all of your links in reciprocal way or
overthinking this by trying to link to
somebody else who links to a third party
that third party links for you don't
waste your time this is just not a
factor that you should worry about
reciprocal links are not generally as
good as one way links but it happened so
often it is not it is not worthy of your
time or any kind of investment trying to
avoid this
hyperlinks act as votes of popularity on
the web the three basic principles of
link building are linked worthy content
proactive off-site engagement offline
relationships the value of an inbound
hyperlink is dictated by the ranking
value of the webpage that contains the
given hyperlink the ranking value of
that webpage the one that contains the
given hyperlink depends on the value of
the pages that link to it so for example
a link from the united nations website
is more valuable than the link from a
random spam spam blog because the united
nations website has more valuable links
plan it than the unpopular spam blog
links from social media are generally
either nofollowed or inaccessible to
search engines this means that while
they may drive traffic and sales they
won't necessarily provide SEO value hey
once you become an expert in digital
marketing then subscribe to the simply
learned channel and click here to watch
more such videos turn up and get
certified in digital marketing click
here